black's never ever gonna make any
progress but he doesn't do that all
pawns on dart squares and there we go
ding
putting his king on
uh in front of that pawn and magnus just
waiting
but passive waiting is not what we
advocate normally and also magnus
doesn't believe in fortresses and here
he's pretty much just trying to build a
fortress he's just trying to wait with
the black rook and
okay there we go
the white pawn stepping forward magnus
shaking his head
he knows that checkmate in three moves
is threatened basically
white's king is just gonna step one
square to the side the white rook is
gonna come across we have to show this i
think because uh
let's keep an eye on the players because
magnus might resign any moment but
checkmate is coming and
actually magnus i thought he was about
to resign he's leaning forward looking
for one final way to defend
and
there's not even stalemate i was
thinking maybe there's some stairmating
ideas but no and he resigns
wow world number three dingley wren in
the early early morning in china